did you know that over 80 of the
grass-fed beef sold in the u.s is
imported from overseas
now the good ranchers have traveled the
country on a mission to help the
american family by working together with
local farms and ranches and shipping
straight to your door goodranchers.com
is a safe and convenient way to order
your meat they save your family money
they help the american farmer
goodranchers.com
they deliver american craft beef better
than organic chicken they've got t-bones
fillets strips gourmet burgers and more
i had the gourmet burgers for dinner
about what four or five nights ago and
they were excellent they were superb i
the strips are fabulous too those those
are generally my kind of cuts that i
would go for they've got unbelievable
quality really great prices you'll be
helping america putting america first go
to goodranchers.com to buy now or
subscribe today and save 20 on each box
of mouth-watering meats subscribing
brings the cost down to less than five
bucks a meal right now you get an extra
20 bucks off and free express shipping
go to goodranchers.com knowles use
codenoles at checkout 20 bucks off and
free express shipping goodranchers.com
knowles know where your meat comes from
with goodranchers.com
tony hawk
tony hawk
a figure from the childhood of many
millennials tony hawk
skateboarding
star video game skateboarding star
tony hawk's releasing a skateboard that
includes some of his own blood in it
it's weird and a little bit creepy i
guess the idea is you know i put my
blood sweat and tears into skateboarding
you know you can have some of that too
okay whatever i think it's kind of weird
and creepy but lil nas x who is that
satanist
rapper
he came out
and he said quote now that tony hawk has
released skateboards with his blood
painted on them and there was no public
outrage are you all ready to admit you
all were never actually upset over the
blood in the shoes and maybe you were
mad for some other reason
little nas x you'll recall when he
released his satanist music video where
he's literally twerking on satan and
saying like hell's maybe not the worst
place in the world and we can make
ourselves into the king of hell
i did a did a long exegesis
a long reading and analysis of that
music video which you can check out
elsewhere
little massax released these nike
sneakers
that included
pentagrams and scriptural references to
lucifer to satan
and
allegedly a drop of human blood
and people were up in arms over this
he says well tony hawk used blood too
so this is it's you you're just coming
after me because i'm gay you're just
coming after me because i'm black i
don't know you're just because i'm
oppressed
it wasn't the blood per se that people
were upset about
necessarily or well that wasn't a big
part of it
it was what the blood represented
for tony hawk he doesn't have pentagrams
he doesn't have
numerical and scriptural references to
satan
it's just like a weird marketing ploy
you did
it was about
i think at least for me the outrage was
about the overt satanism
but you hear this all the time and this
is a broader
problem that you hear in politics
they'll say michael if you
think that we should regulate
pornography then you're no better than
the left which says that we should
censor conservatives on the internet
you're no different michael no i think
i'm very different because pornography
and first amendment protected political
speech are different yes the form
censorship is the same
but the substance of what you're
censoring
is different
yes the the
symbol here the blood is the same
but the significance of that is
different
and i think we just need to be able to
talk more about
substantive matters this is this was the
david french's big problem when he said
if we ban drag queen story hour then
they're going to ban us from going to
church that was the implication at least
what he was saying
we can know the difference we can i
promise you
we possess the faculties of reason and
the moral conscience sufficient to tell
the difference between drag queen story
hour and going to church on sunday
sufficient to tell the difference
between
a skateboard marketing gimmick and
an overt satanic liturgy we can do that
we actually
we actually possess those faculty for
now we do for now i actually do maybe
not for much longer
what
what are we doing who are this guy it
all comes back to afghanistan i think
this is why afghanistan is such a
lightning rod
you can't build up another country
another civilization another set of
principles and practices and another way
of life
if you do not possess one yourself or if
the one that you once did possess is
disintegrating all around you
[Music]
[Music]
you